hey freund letzter tag hier in rage
abreise koffer ist gepackt hier unten
und ja es war sehr cool dem hotel hier
und ein bisschen spät dran eigentlich
ein c check out und york möglich sagen
machen uns auf den weg
morgen im flug
wir haben viereinhalb stunden zeit
wir wissen nicht genau was sie machen
werden in der ganzen zeit vielleicht
kann ich nicht lache du kannst aber noch
ein video hochladen unglaublich jahre
werden es massen auf jeden fall auch
sich dass wir uns mehr allzu sehr
langweilig naja der stadt leben bei uns
abgegeben 13 und jetzt werden wir noch
mal drei stunden oder so was
nach manchester rein so freuen wir sind
jetzt im zug der fährt in zehn minuten
los und dann sind wir in manchester und
gucken uns einfach nur hier schluss und
wurden aufgefordert nicht zu finden ja
aber wir sehen wir fielen trotzdem
liga
red
use
angekommen jetzt schauen wir was wir
machen können
bild manchester
freunde hier sind wir und wir wissen
nicht stimmen zum starbucks kessel und
wahrscheinlich wird für ausdrücklich
kurz bleiben
der arbeitsbereich kompressors dem
besser als zu waschen an bank für am
flughafen luqa warten ist die größte
kacke und sollte wäre nicht aufgrund der
aktualität als 100 ist ja schon wieder
zu wir waren manchester und wir haben
video bereich wo wir englische leute im
deutschen setzte vorlesen das namen ich
würde ich mal wissen was ein kräftig der
rest des platzes
das ganze video gibt's auf jeden fall
bei luca auf dem kanal und gar kein
bisschen klein angewandt und dass lukas
video an arbeitskosten lustig wesentlich
besser als im war im flughafen zugang
herstellern und da ging es aber wieder
händen zu greifen und dann geht's nach
deutschland
zehn menschen
aus
juli
mit
jetzt gehen wir nun wirklich komisch an
machte jeder auflagen für jede aufnahme
liga
de la b
die jungs sehen
so freunde wird jetzt angekommen im
düsseldorfer flughafen wir bereiten uns
auf unseren zug ihr und paar
abschließende worte zum wave chip also
ich fand es war richtig cool einfach so
landschaften zweiter damals das ganz
alternatives irgendwie so zu statt
urlaub in action und alles möglich wobei
action hatten wir auch mehr als genug
oder 2
meine begleitung war auch nicht durch
ein plötzlich sagen und insgesamt was
auf jeden fall paar tage war es relativ
ruhig
ich hoffe euch jetzt auch gefallen
guckt auf jeden fall auch die blogs von
luca an er ist natürlich der
beschreibung verlinkt und dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder rein und fällt das
immer nach oben auf der special